[Music]
in unorthodox method news hmm
submitted by Monday's slanty face I'm so
bad it used to be when I went to school
or when I had work yeah no I don't go oh
my god mom boy these just blend together
now lucky a woman is facing criticism
after claiming she cured an aggressive
child with the rabid wait with rabid dog
saliva what right please give me what
country can we play can we play guess
the country Russia yeah any other
countries India China not just one just
one
I was thinking Indian bone Asia no new
jackets dad what Dagestan is that it
yeah it's part of like the USSR or like
part of Russia called Russia none of you
are right this is actually in Canada
why oh no wonder it's an outrage because
it doesn't rush like what do you mean
everybody
there's rabid dog dog with rabies I got
that say once yes the dog with rabies so
is our Israelis contagious to the
slightest yes I think so
it's like bite everybody if their saliva
goes into your bloodstream
yeah you drink a Raby saliva doesn't
that make you get the rabies that's what
people are saying they're like this is
so ridiculous like what's next you're
gonna look this one person tweeted may
God help us all what's next injecting
with tuberculosis for anorexia leprosy
for eczema doesn't like isn't like
rabies literally literally like our form
of like turning to a zombie look isn't
it like mad cow disease yeah makes you
going right it's not like it it's like
you got [ __ ] me you know it's not
scary if you don't get it treated within
24 hours then you basically you're gonna
die well rabies
yeah that's why bad is shuo Yeller man
oh oh here Yeller
come back Yeller and rabies you got to
get a shot in your stomach right like
into your belly button or some machine
that was that was the rumor that all the
like daycare teachers like we would play
it out in the field
don't pick those Gophers that are coming
out of the field she can't tell me not
to pet them I'm petting so I forgot what
it was but if you get bit by something
and and you get the vaccinations within
a certain time you don't get that but if
it gets too far you have to get one in
the stomach or something well I think
the vaccination is only good if you get
it before you get bitten really yeah
look this [ __ ] up cuz I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about
it's just vaccinations as before
whatever it's like just in case [ __ ]
happens so like you get a vaccination if
you know you're gonna go somewhere where
there's like animals and then if you get
bit then you don't get rabies
whatever the shot at humans rabies is
almost always fatal afternoon
neurological symptoms have developed
although vaccine after exposure is
highly successful in preventing the
disease if administered properly within
six days of infection still short though
that's shortest [ __ ] that's true yeah
that's true cuz if I'm like in the
wilderness and then like I'm like days
away from any place yesterday rabid
animal
yes so this homeopathic doctor from
Romeo path doctor
okay good cuz i usually pronounce things
wrong alright so this doctor dr.
Zimmerman recently wrote about an
interesting case on her website where
she cured a four-year-old named Jonah
who had trouble sleeping No partly
because or there's more partly because
he was afraid of werewolves werewolves
and would hide under tables and growl at
people and he's a werewolf
he's normal yeah and then apparently
like he liked meats particularly
hamburgers hot dogs and meatballs
sounds like a warrior okay I agree he
sounds like a [ __ ] Guido we don't
create them yeah he didn't like to be
coddled but instead we're wolf I get it
yeah
that he would sniff nuzzle and lick his
mother like a dog Oh cute he [ __ ] has
a great imagine exactly yeah so then
this doctor she ended up asking for the
scariest phone club no I saw right
through that 20/20 baby this doctor
asked the mom if the kid had recently
been been bitten by a dog
oh and the mom said yes but they were at
the beach or apparently when he was two
years old he they were at the beach and
a dog big bits his hand because he
wanted food and it did break skin and so
this doctor was saying that obviously
this kid is dogs state slightly rabies
flavored dogs bait to be more precise
rabies flavored so what she wrote you
don't got to be whimsical about diseases
yeah what the [ __ ] it's just but as
doctor all you needed to do is bring
that kid back to the beach to [ __ ] up
that dog for revenge that was two years
prior we'll find a need uncle get a dog
at the dog pound and then wrestle have
the kid beat it up so they this doctor
was saying that that dog probably
recently like from the time he bit the
kid was just cured from rabies and then
somehow gave that to the kid
wait how would you know if the dog was
just cured for maybe because he turned
the kid into a dog you transferred the
rabies over to the kid no exactly as
homeopathic medicine is it like when you
didn't go get a PhD in medicine is it
fake is that what it is it's a good home
remedy doctor yeah and actually there's
like it's Eastern medicine so a lot of
like a lot of there's a lot of success
with stuff but this person just sounds
like crazy
I hope Tiger thinks he's like a werewolf
or not a human and stuff that'd be so
[ __ ] cool yeah yeah cuz I'm like cool
like [ __ ] explore that part of your
brain and like what if he goes that
moons out I ain't going to sleep then
I'm like [ __ ] but you better wake up
early when I tide wake up I'm gonna beat
your ass oh yeah you see
works my kid would none of that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he wanted us to call him monster truck
cuz he thought he was a monster yeah
high speed gasoline Downers no we would
call him
we're like Ethan come here and then he
wouldn't like you wouldn't listen and
we're like oh yeah right he's monster
truck hey monster truck he's like boom
boom okay
dumbass I don't identify us Ethan
anymore hey Denis is this monster sure I
like it yeah I'll change mom yeah he was
so cool oh my god well let me change
your tires which he's had to rip off
your [ __ ] leg yeah kick it on a
werewolf baby come on yeah so what
something she fed it dog drool in it and
the kids stop that dog created a cure
that had lice listen many of them some
[ __ ] listen listen listen
Doreen listen them you're right David
it's Listerine yes then she gave him
that several times over a few months
over a few my parent Lee that's what
cured his condition and that he no
longer hides or growls I people he's no
longer afraid of werewolves cuz he's
dead
so what is listen I may not exactly but
I would like to go to a non science
doctor they'll be pretty cool maybe we
should do a whole show about it was
actually really good natural remedies
for things but I don't know I mean like
when there's certain things like oh
honey we'll help you with allergies like
stuff like that I could believe it but I
mean drinking rabies to cure your dog
tendencies that's kind of listen um what
is it um so okay so the College of
naturopathic physicians of British
Columbia stands by those doctors cure
they said what the [ __ ] is a
pathological doctor naturopathic
naturopathic just because you put titles
before it sounds official
it just sounds like another gypsy ass
doctor
the [ __ ] organization of crystal ball
says I think there's only two like
widely accepted modes of medicine once
osteopathic I think that's where it's a
deal after our MDS are but allopathic
Minnesota I don't know but there's like
that's a type of medicine that they
practice but I don't think I've ever had
a homeopathic and the natural path he
has a mother was actually pretty popular
yeah it's huge yeah a lot there's a lot
of homeopathic remedies and you can go
to [ __ ] Whole Foods and there's a
whole section about the problem wait is
it acupuncture considered home I think
so that's also probably it's a huge
umbrella though that's why a lot of
snake oil salesmen and fake stirs can
get in yeah cuz homeopathic I think the
literal definition is just it's just
like holy [ __ ] or whatever natural
remedies but naturopathic doctors are
called Indies
they are general practitioners of
natural metal what's the MD because
that's the most legit medicine medical
doctor what type of medicine though the
prescription drugs
it's like allopathic or there's some
other Pathak for MD I think the way you
separate the two is one uses science and
there's a peer review and they test the
hypothesis and all that stuff and then
the other one is just feelings so if
everyone goes I feel I feel like the
homie right here is great
homeopathy yeah that's a homie
eight-ball and see what you need a tape
and that's why the organization gets
together they don't know how to [ __ ]
test in research let me get a trillion
people to do this rabies medicine and
then go okay we test it and then now our
group backs it it's more like believe
him I could kind of see that happening
that's how they work have you guys ever
gotten acupuncture before yes and it
does work yeah my entire childhood for
no reason what is that when they cook
what anyone a blood shoots out of your
students needles in you and it redirects
the energy is what it does supposedly
that's like the the theory behind it
ah guys I mean I worked for me and I
crazy back pains and the only thing
that's ever worked has been acupuncture
at or regular massage it's like going on
the race the quickest way that I've ever
experienced recovering from a sprain
yeah same thing happen to Mary oh
because her mom does acupuncture right
yeah and then she sprained her [ __ ] and
her mom did the acupuncture stat and I
was like [ __ ] looks good yeah so I'm
saying like some homeopathic stuff is
like really legit but like they're like
you said there's a lot of snake oil
people that try to sling things and and
then I understand you know centuries of
testing that's like the Asian version of
a MD but then that's also bundled up
with all the other creatures there's a
lot of law there's also a lot of
lobbyists in the pharmaceutical industry
that like just one of those people
pumped up on medicine so that you get
addicted to it and they continue to take
your money so there's like there's good
and bad in both areas yeah yeah so then
back to this so the College of
naturopathic physicians of British
Columbia they're saying that this dr.
Zimmerman is a is licensed to practice
naturopathic medicine in BC and that so
you can practice crystal ball medicine
and then listen them which is rabid dog
saliva that's what listen Allah is not
excluded from the pharmacopoeia for
naturopathic doctors in DC homeopathy
which includes the use of substances
such as listen them is a traditional
modality with a long history of the
naturopathic scope of practice it is
still used by some naturopathic doctors
today that's what that place said so
we're gonna Dan buy your heart here did
it cure it I mean like is the doctor
saying the kids aren't acting like a
daughter to the doctor's name but
everyone's like you know what right now
I might say all this [ __ ] is stupid but
if some [ __ ] could light up some
sage and dance around me and cure me of
cancer yeah see you dog great like yeah
cuz by that time it cured you for the
legitly then because there's a lot of
people that get sick or whatever and
then they just they go to doctors doctor
and they're like wow I can't figure it
out I don't know what it is and then
they go to some [ __ ] voodoo as doctor
and then they do something like dance
and then they magically throw some dust
on you and [ __ ] and you feel
there's some crazy [ __ ] like um like the
Eastern medicine is like kind of it's
all like that and it I'll pay for
placebos because the thing is put
placebos do work yeah so I'll pay for
that [ __ ] just trick me mm-hmm
[Music]